oh yeah we got a new friend with us
oh hell yeah we're going towards this
dragon so we're in her little
narrative story world right now this is
the story that she's writing
let's go
magic
oh she's she's bouncing a bit
oh there's some funky funky collision
there
they're just trees yeah but lump is
gonna set fire to them and
and cause uh
cause a forest fire so maybe lump is
onto something here
the gray forest dark
foreboding georgia didn't
care oh you lose it
yes that's
[Music]
i need to repair it
no
break it then all right
that's making me really anxious what the
hell
[Music]
i need to find out how is it not setting
fire
to the forest i don't understand i mean
i'm happy about it but i don't
understand it
do you think if i stood underneath that
tree i would have died
that can fly
rise again
[Music]
i am go go push it
push it
lump smoke bigger
so lump used to be an enemy that we kind
of defeated
and by using empathy
okay
nice sliding technique we got there
georgia couldn't help but smile lump's
silliness
her fiery friend was finding a place
near and dear to her heart
suddenly a strange sour smell
cut
oh yeah we said that he had like um
i think the sour fruit so you can kind
of change the story you get to
choose certain aspects of it
we need to go now
but but the fruit
okay
i i see viking woman and my name in the
chat and i'm
liking what i see are we just leaving
that there ah
apparently five foot one was a female
vikings height
finally the ravaged forest
something cool that's that short
dragonfire it's here
uh what do i do repair
what are you oh okay
okay lump trust georgia ask
chase dragon
that's the spirit lump we're near i can
feel it
yes
[Music]
no no no no
we're so close
that's all right spread this tree
oh maybe not it wasn't
meant to happen but the fruit had an
irresistible draw on little
no lump stay here
i need you i'm still here
just busy georgia felt her resolve melt
i need to find the dragon
can i jump on these words
all by myself
not left is in fruit
georgia knew she wouldn't swap that
out
can i swap their positions
[Music]
fair enough
wow what a rush
oh it's too high ah there you go
that was amazing
so um you learn magic words and then you
can use them
rgb lights
uh okay we don't need this anymore oh
far far
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yes
my head's spinning this may be
better than fruit there was no doubt
something strong oh big dragon prince
and very very large
had been here recently
there it is
[Music]
um hey it's shamim
i would say if you're not too sure about
studying at university
um because i wasn't uh
think about like what kind of things you
want to do and then maybe
work for a bit what i did when i wasn't
too sure about uni was
i applied for apprenticeships instead
in like bigger cities than mine and then
i went and worked
in something similar in a company
and then obviously what i said to myself
was if i'm still thinking about uni
after i finish the apprenticeship then
i'll go
because you can go whatever age you want
and i went
at like 21 22
like i went later than most people so uh
don't feel like you have to go to uni
just because everyone else is
and don't feel like you have to go
straight out of school
with little thought for her own safety
you won't get away from me again
i won't let you ah no
come back come back here
oh
falling fast
georgia realized the dragon had gone far
far
below
is it gonna say that i
her hope was shattered i
can't i can't even
we find dragon again have another go
right
it's okay lump help
but how
most of the pieces are
i can't even fix it look
who gets on this okay
i i don't even know where i'm going
anymore
what am i doing i'm such an idiot
no don't do that negative talk don't do
it
look one of them's little glowy things
he likes
a firefly
a thing you like things too
right what what do you mean a thing huh
that's
strange maybe there are some people
around here
uh hey thomas yes i have played limbo a
long time ago
but i have played it in though yeah and
inside inside was great
look stuff
yeah clumsy dragon flimsy
well there was also like wooden boxes
back along that way but i imagine i'm
not going back
maybe i can most likely not
i can
but i doubt i think i'm wasting time
nah i can't grab it she's tiny how is
she gonna carry that
hey eve son
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
is
you don't remember anything
ah i guess that was all the
this happens when i accidentally press w
like just before
us and then she does this weird little
like skid thing
okay ancient energy stirred
reaching into the place beyond
already it's only been a few millennia
is it not wonderful to see light again
to feel
sun i was just getting comfortable in
the howling void
who are you too oh ancient
ones i thought you was a myth
no no my little friend we are very real
no we're not you're imagining us
go away that's the typical
good and evil nice and
not nice grumpy
but nothing is free in this market or
in life you must provide three offerings
to the flame
should we
if help human if it make
human happy
things end up here that have been cast
aside or are no longer useful
after a time so were we no one came
i thought we would forget ourselves but
you brought us back
you said you could help
i don't then give a kindness
you want to like play fluffy i could hug
you all day i
don't think we're going for that one uh
you look wonderful today okay that's a
bit better
i'll tell everyone about you don't wanna
oh this one definitely
i'll tell everyone about you no one will
ever forget you again
what kind of you to say now i will
return the favor
to get your wish you must submit an
offering of hope to the flames
something dear to your heart elder gave
me this
what did she give her i absolutely
forgot with hopeful memories
i don't know if i should it was the last
hey perez a wise person once said
that no one ever got anything just by
wanting it okay
you're right
what about you what do you want i said
go away
this is a market right look
my help it's not the kind you need
it isn't why
does he deal with like trade in oblivion
oh i feast on
memories
but you can still help me
i have to find out why a dragon attacked
my village
well don't come complaining to me when
there's a
big dark hole in your head
what memory are you prepared
oh oh oh i was supposed to choose one of
these and then
give one of them my pendant thanks a
follower in frass
eight three three five
um should i do this
let's give him like a memory that
doesn't matter as much
[Music]
the offering has been made
do you think they take another memory
the last offering must keep a fire
burning oh
it must be lump gesture of hope of
friendship
but it cannot be given by you
you have something to give
sure i got
yourself to help your friend
of course lump
you don't have to do this there must be
another way
this is important to human you freed
lump you gave lump memories
it's a it's my best friend's birthday
today amy just saying and i think she
would love lamp
i'm just listening like yeah amy would
be like that's so cute
uh i
don't want lump to give up himself i
want you to do this
lump i know
but love decide this
it is important you made promise
to find dragon love
helps
okay goodbye for us
hello for you and dragon
as little lump jumped into the fire the
flames began to burn
larger and brighter
amy doesn't have a calm
georgia felt a change come over
slits opened in her neck gills
she can now breathe underwater she's
just picked up some kitty weed
the wish has been granted time for us to
go
hope you like your gift back into the
void with you
i'll never forget what you did
i should go to the lake
follow the dragon
i guess
nah amy would want a face cam the loss
of lump wave
heavily upon
and um she's actually um gone down
well maybe i shouldn't talk about
personal life but she's doing fun stuff
for her birthday
where once there was light was now
darkness
where there was noise only cold silence
remained
but she could not let lump's sacrifice
be in vain
she needed to get to the lake and use
her newfound powers to pursue the dragon
now that is a compliment for us damn
the lake let's use our gills but she had
to brave its depths
okay i thought i just fell i was like um
am i doing the right thing
no i said i haven't been to a
pub in like over a year
it's 5 a.m
oh no grand diet
in the night no
we knew it was coming guys this is it
the mum got the call a few hours ago
she's still crying i just
feel
oh we get to choose oh no i think it's
just
no it's just all of these feelings she
feels all of this
i tried to go back to sleep
let's go but as soon as i close
my eyes the thoughts keep
circling back should have been there
should have been there
um it's so sad is that
should no we should have been there
we should have been there
one said much
it seemed to take forever
no that's cool
i've never seen a deaf body before
[Music]
it might be scary
[Music]
right
maybe i should have stayed at home
no you'd forget it finally arrived
i wasn't so sure about being there at
all
we went up the stairs
to room 305.
gran's room
mum gently put her hand on my
back
and asked me if i wanted to wait outside
i said
yes
fair enough
i'm sitting in the waiting room just
rows of plastic
benches in a sea of blue linoleum
and it smells like ben's bottom cream
yeah a little doodling should distract
me
from this dreary place
he's a good doodle that's calling me
[Music]
i've never seen her like this
mums aren't supposed to cry
ready they're strong
you can be strong and cry i am meant to
know what to do
always
i guess losing your own mum makes you
feel
like a kid again
the drive home was a quiet
one again it's silly
but i keep thinking back to graham's
favorite bars the one granddad gave her
i was running in the house
even though graham had told me not to
oh no i still remember the noise
of the bus smashing
into little pieces gran was there in an
instant
i waited for her to shout
she didn't she just looked
sad and somehow
that was worse
gran wouldn't let me
pick up the pieces she found
every single one
and carried them into the kitchen
later i sneaked in
with a tube of glue in hand
oh i should put the pieces back together
does that go with that what the hell's
happening here
yeah like this
it was a mess
i got glue everywhere
but gran smiled when she saw the bars
she put it in the cupboard
[Music]
later i found this again
in the bin
[Music]
when i asked her why she bend the vars
she smiled again graham
always says we can't hold on to
the onto
[Music]
memories lots of memories now
hold on to things forever let them
live in your memories okay
let them live in your memories she said
she preferred to keep the vast like she
remembered it
maybe i hurt gran's heart
weakened it that can happen
can't it maybe this is all my fault
i should have listened to her i
shouldn't have ran in the house
now everything is broken
i could i could have
fixed i
would have fixed her heart
stupid bookmark
really i don't even know how to fix
my story it's a mess
i left georgia to sink into cold
dark waters she's completely
alone she left behind lump
her only friend okay
focus he
how can i continue the story
how would she feel about this situation
georgia felt
hmm
i'm had to stay so george you're on no
easy answers here
of guilty ambivalent guilt i'm just
going to go with guilty because that
would be how i would feel
guilty for you guessing someone
ambivalent is probably a better one to
choose though
okay back in the 3d world ah do you see
what i mean you go to like
from her imaginary world but it's all
kind of sweet and cute and then you get
to the journal and you're like
so sad so relatable
the merchants had been true to their
offer
still the water closing over her felt
like
death cold
and terrifying
i can breathe she's got gills
strange wish lump could have been there
hey han jisung thanks for subscribing
to dwell on her lost friend georgia had
a dragon to find
which way did it go
i don't know let's go right this one
all right another branching tunnel
just keep going right the walls were
closing in
down here i guess right far
too narrow for winged beasts did i guess
wrong yeah probably
a dead end oh can i swim upwards
oh [ __ ] wrong tunnel
oh cool
[Music]
how do i get up there huh
is this the right way
this is really cool or maybe here
i don't know i just keep going right
i wish i could ask lump
but georgia had let lump go
she needed to decide her own path alone
the submerged
tunnels flared outwards a tangled mess
of caverns and hollows
twisting and turning
bending with almost malicious intent
i need to get out of here
well i think i need's good oh i think
there's a firefly up there
i think i need to go down down down
down down down down
hey panic disconnect
okay this is a big one breathe
georgia breathe
all of this happened
why isn't why is working
i think i'm dying what's happening
she found herself amidst a great coral
bed
shimmering with color and life
wow this is beautiful
no i have to find the dragon
no matter what beautiful and
now
broken
it goes back right
hopefully now it does
she spoke those words
but deep in her heart
a seed of chilling doubt took root
the color gave way to darkness endless
you might um come across like a giant
squid or something
robbed of sight
the pressure of the deep water on her
chest
yeah the pressure it's not gonna be
and for what i don't even know where the
dragon
is
that's another one wake cthulu from a
slumber
huh a shark
ah
are you sure it's not just your kills
what's this
what was that evil evil
okay wait can i break this no i can't
break's gone now
damn i she's got repair
how it doesn't matter
i need to find the dragon no matter
what that's cool
she just disappeared wait what
all right i'm supposed to prepare the
bridge gotcha glad you got it
a cold determination gripped her
numbing all other
there was just the way forward barred by
an
indestructible metal door
no no
find
the dragon
georges should no longer ignore the seed
of doubt
what we're gonna do ignore the door
ignore the door so we can walk through
the door
that's a great idea
[Music]
hey have you
seen the dragon
wait cute
oh my men my people
[Music]
i'm not here oh my god i wish i could do
this in real life
not that like everyone comes up to me or
anything i just wish i could just be
like
invisible
[Music]
then again this is making others
invisible
i mean walking through locked doors by
turning it invisible it's a
it's a unique concept
destiny this is meant to be a prank from
the spooky games
freezing cold blanketed georgia
there was comfort in its numbing embrace
she wished she could stay
what's happening
she did this is this
my fault it was her fault
i
i destroyed it how
because of like her sadness but surely
that wouldn't have made that thing
explode i don't think it was her fault
sydney that's a really good shout i
guess she is starting to ignore people
in
real life encased in ice oh
is that burnout or something no
oh no what have i done
i'm so sorry please
forgive me i never wanted this
can i jump up here
i should never have come
what would elder ava think of me
i'm so selfish
guilt docked her every step
oh dogged did you make me do
this
it's like guilt oh it's because i chose
guilt interesting so maybe that wouldn't
no surely this would have happened
either way can i talk to you
hello hello okay i'll keep going
it would not rest i have no magic words
now
it would not cease
leave me alone
the dog's still
i need to there
it could definitely get me
please i didn't know
show
the creature looked at her as if it
could see
into her very soul
under its stare her fears crystallized
like ice
she knew that she would be eaten
disappear be crushed i'll let you guys
decide this one
seeing as i've chosen all the other ones
what do you want disappear
eaten crushed
it's up to you
i'll just uh wait for the lag to catch
up
[Music]
and jamie says that disappear is the
least brutal that's that's very true
that's very true what was i i was
thinking
be eaten or crushed uh
but that's right disappear is
probably the most no most definitely the
the
kindest one that we could choose
okay we're going with disappear
disappear
you're a savage disappear into
nothingness
i can't let that happen
yeah at least at least you guys aren't
run from monsters
georgia's lucky that you know she's got
you guys at least
have to fight it
can't
keep moving moving
hello journal
dear journal
hi journal
i've today
hmm
so
hello hello stranger i've been thinking
a lot about
my dream is to become a writer
yeah right
[Music]
a writer who can't
even write
okay find something simple to start with
what did i do today
today i got up
i had breakfast
i tried watching the telly
that's it i'm going back to bed
oh hi
another day
oh i can't go that way each time i wake
up
for the tunes
it it
isn't isn't true
but then it all comes rushing back
it is true
looking around my room everything
reminds me of gran
her puzzle box gift from last year
the magic tank we made during the
holiday
oh yeah
our yogurt pot robot
saw that when they cleaned the room
thanks for following barrett 95.
very weird time to go happy this pen
even you journal
she is everywhere
[Music]
and all of it feels broken
[Music]
today is ben's birthday
dad baked a cake
mum insisted that i come down
and have some
[Music]
it tasted like
nothing
everything does
mum said we need to send out invitations
to the funeral
how can she think about that
she's ready to shove bran into a box
like a
pet goldfish
oh
how do i okay
then i stormed off into my room
no
later dad came up for some
well-meant dad talk
i know you're sad but it will get
better you'll see
just give it time i know he wanted to
get a dad voice
he's wrong
the world feels very dark now
gran has a proverb for times like these
graham always says
it's always
darkest before dawn it's always darkest
before the door no
that's not right is it not that's what
she would have said
ah
i keep thinking about all the things
gran won't get to see
when i go to university
she won't be there
when i get my first job she won't be
there
ugh this is too sad
if i get married she won't be there
even if that's unlikely because
oh sorry carlos i got a mechanical
boy boys
but how could i want that feeling to go
away
how could i be fine with cran
being gone i'm going to have to feel
like this
forever
thanks pinky
hmm i can't stop crying
pinkie is probably getting fed up with
being used as a tissue
but she never leaves my side
i think that means
get back to writing your story
cats are so awesome they really do know
when you're sad
i miss having a cat
i think he's got a point
i should at least try to write
i can't leave georgia like that
my head
where am i
a grey void surrounded her
swallowing sound and hope
hello
georgia guessed that if she kept moving
it's really surely a solution itself
do you know what that one says is
someone here
anyone in the environment it's the word
limbo
she found a hut a palace
hope i
i don't know what comes next it's so
cold here so empty
just nothingness
did the dog get us i can't
they won't come the words just
won't come anymore i don't know
me when i'm trying to write a new song
or even where i'm going pointless
what kind of writer can't find the words
i missed everything up
let's try this again
georgia awake under an old tree
in an unfamiliar land i don't know
if i can do this anymore yeah i think
this just represents her
like um uncertainty
like you know if you've got something
especially if you're creative in any way
and you try and do the thing
that sometimes comes so easy and other
times
just not coming and then you doubt
everything about yourself
my take i'm so tired
georgia knew she just had to keep going
what's the point put one foot
in front of the other i've failed well
she still had breath left in her body
there was still hope this is all my
fault i should just
stop
am i going too far do i need to stop
alone
useless
damn this is like
hey georgia
leave me just leave me
here
where i don't see a thing
cool
i'm right here always was
always will be i don't understand
and i don't care this is a really good
way of explaining mental health to kids
no just leave
i'm meant to be alone
forever alone and useless
you know i'm right below you i'm not
good
company right now
you don't need to be why don't about
that you came to be
here i
it sounds silly when i say it now
i lost a dragon and
now
um i lost the dragon and now
i just don't know what to do next i'm
completely lost
as well it's all gone terribly wrong
i'm just tired i'm gonna say the last
one
i'm just tired
that's okay it's not
people are relying on me
but you're still human you still tire
we all do i can't let things overwhelm
me
i'm tired tired of trying
tired of failing
tired of everything
you need a rest but i can't
i don't have time
why if i can find out
why this happens maybe i can find out
how to stop it
that sounds like quite a tiring thing to
do
well yes
want to take a rest together
that sounds nice
gonna have a nap gonna have enough for
the shark
okay
i like listening to you would you
continue
you do it's just
i completely messed everything up i'm so
completely yesterday lost i'm just kind
of so confused right now
that's what she thinks i completely
messed everything up
i just don't know what to do next
but at some point you knew right you had
purpose
hope yes
i knew exactly what i needed to do
i had to stop the dragon return the
fireflies
save the village and
you couldn't do those things
i tried but
i just ended up doing everything wrong
everything are you sure about that
well
think back okay
maybe not everything
go on i managed not to get
squashed by a flaming giant dust oh yeah
we made friends with them
that was lump
do i keep falling asleep so i'm so tired
go on
i'll wait
what was she asking i don't know where i
am
or even who i am i'm lost i have no idea
what to do now
that one it's not personal i don't know
where i am
or even who i am
i'm lost could you
help me become a little hey pro-dark
wolf
i don't think that is a word
that's not entirely helpful
you seem to think that it's wrong to be
lost
well isn't it
everyone feels a little lost sometimes
even me you do
really i don't mind it
actually do you
well yes i
usually know what to do and where to go
so if someone else hey moon face
fear no evil i tell them
to not worry so much just
continue on until a solution you're
playing a very sad
narrative game how about taking your own
advice
okay that makes sense
if i had a landmark i could orientate
myself
by it let me see if i can help you out
there
patience
patience
i want to know one more thing
you sound a lot better i do
oh she's been sleeping i guess so well
then
it's nice of you so listen to me anytime
so anything else
well yeah this one i guess i don't know
what were you trying to do before you
got here
i was trying to find it i need to know
why it did this that but
i just like what did you do last time
last time i walked found a dragon what
i've never found one before then how can
you expect to know exactly what to do
i guess i can't no one ever got anything
just by wanting it you've got to try
you've got to fail sometimes you have a
point
yes yes yes yes yes yes failing
is a step towards succeeding
this is where i leave but
i you're not alone
you are loved be kind to yourself
[Music]
hey you're a terror man
[Music]
bye shark can i
do this yes
be your own light in the darkness
bye shark i'll try
oh absolutely sydney i think especially
with code a lot of people are scared to
get code wrong or you know just beat
themselves up when they realize the
mistakes that they've made
usually just they get in a bloody
semicolon isn't it but
once you start to do it more and fail
more you just get more comfortable with
it
here we go again
ah we're coming back up
hello journal of course that shark was
on the
front of this journal
mum and dad dressed all in black
they even bought a black romper for ben
i didn't want to wear black
brown thought black was depressing
that life was
dark enough already
gran always used to say
colors are the music of nature
colors are the music of nature
i'm starting to see what she meant
so i went to open my wardrobe
there it was i hadn't worn it for years
i remember grand saying it was
cheery
the funeral was outside
in the memorial garden
the sun was shining
the birds were singing
it was like they didn't know
the vicara just started talking
when uncle alan stepped into the
fishbond
i couldn't help but imagine
crown caring more about the fish
than uncle allen
picture stuck in my head
grand running to the trent's uncle allen
crumbling at him for frightening with
this
it was too much the laughter bubbled up
inside me
dad tried the lithanoid
oh right can i just can i can i can i
after the vicar finally
finished droning on
we started the singing oh
[Music]
[Music]
hold on hold on i haven't made it yet
one side one side level got one coming
ben started wailing
no howling dad took him out
well played then laughing felt
much better than crying the wake
was at our place there were so
many people
i didn't know most of them everyone said
how sorry they were
how gran was such a wonderful lady
i wish she could have heard them
hmm that's cute
everyone had a story about graham
like the time she hit a bully with her
pencil box
or when she saved a toad it had hurt its
leg
cute or how she decorated mom's room
like an
underwater kingdom oh cool so she could
feel
like a mermaid that's so like her
one old lady told me how they used to
bunk off
work and go to the glastonbury music
festival
another of her friends said gran once
got arrested
i mean it's not cool but i just wouldn't
expect that
and this sweet little grandma
she probably got arrested um because she
was you know
fighting for her rats and what she
believed in
uh when i need to go over there
well protesting wailing yeah protesting
nice
hippie cute
i expected this day
to be terrible journal and it was
but i didn't expect to smile
or laugh to be surprised
to feel happy that people
loved grand like i did
each time i heard a story about graham
i could imagine her laughing along with
it
it was like she was there with me
helping me through it
oh thanks scram i still
feel in pieces john
maybe there's a part of me that will
always be sad that we'll
always miss her but
maybe that's okay
and that's the way the cookie crumbles
i don't know what happens after we die
hey gail but i
think i know where we go into
all the people who have ever
cared about us we make a sort of place
that's really sweet and i'm hot
getting emotional
i need to finish george's story
gran would want me to i want me to
i think i know what to do now
let's summarize after the dragon
attacks her village the playful georgia
set out to return the fireflies
on her travels she met a grumpy gin
guarding a fallen city of merchants
and found a misunderstood
fire creature
they became friends
but then lump was forced
to stay behind for the ancient ones
in exchange for the gift of water
breathing
deep under the water
inside the lost seeking palace chased by
the shadow of remorse
georgia had her big moment of doubt
but she pulled through it all
and now she's ready yes
and now she is ready what what
face the dragon
you're so emotional
where am i
oh here you
i thought i couldn't face you
but i couldn't face myself
i know you'll always be there
maybe that's okay you're part of this
adventure
because of me thank you have you got
ourselves another doggie friend
oh no oh okay bye now
i thought i was gonna have fun
i'm coming for you dragon no wait no
doggo
unfortunately
a newfound power oh hell yeah
we got so many words now so let's repair
i feel like i can do
i thought you said lice jamie but you
put ice
change the colors
yeah wow
life
like cutting through
glass
crab apple pie much cooler
oh yeah we can do the oh they don't have
the silence
the world welcomed her
don't need the silent all right come on
uh this game is is called lost words it
should be in the title
lost words beyond the page i mean moon
face
[Music]
forward
[Music]
[Music]
nobody saw that that didn't happen
a tall tower loomed overhead
many moons had shone above i gotta go
about 11 so i'm hoping there's not too
much left
in this game i don't think so
hell yeah she's so optimistic now
what's this
after what i've been through i really
think that will stop me
what's this
it was prophesized
a lone figure stood
unbound defiantly it
drew her to it her foe rose
before her no breath in its body
but no less terrifying
what squeeze
swap
let's hope i'm up to the task
oh ominous
hmm okay
oh right of course
oh what did that do nothing's moving
must be more to do
i don't need light
that's it
a ghost of fresh air rewarded george's
efforts
let's go what
that statue is levitating
as she rose up the stairs
where is the hole okay
george and you
the tower's purpose
oh yeah what's that oh come on
to watch over a long forgotten land
should ancient evil stir no statue this
time
there's a dragon
i should totally make that a light it's
in there that's so funny
maybe this wasn't such a good idea
it was a great idea get the drums out
that was close
oh round two
the world darkened around
georgia she had reached the dragon's
mountain
for the first time georgia felt no
fear she knew she had all
she needed go
feels warm with my souls
before a molten sea stretched into the
distance
it did not slow her down it's okay we
can just ignore it
and everything will be fine i love the
face of lava
hey mantas no worries thanks for
dropping by
suddenly georgia no longer felt the heat
in instead a cold dread
crept up her spine
[Music]
what's all the way up here
a firefly
this looks like i was gonna say this
looks like
it can't be very recognizable it has to
be
an eerily familiar sight awaited home
that's my house how
no wait come back
oh no no no
only emptiness remained
let's jump right into it only
emptiness remained okay maybe i
shouldn't jump and do it this time
maybe i should i'm writing that again
only emptiness remained okay so maybe i
need to turn back
her thoughts raced ahead of her
that was quite funny
this can't be real a trick
i can't let it be real
she gripped the chain
with furious determination
i know you're there
we're suddenly back in the water
oh yeah we're in the water
torn between rage and regret
georgia pushed ever upwards
no oil dude
wait rise
rise
[Music]
okay obviously can only rise here isn't
it
what the frick
all right rise oh my god
okay i'm just i'm just okay maybe i can
only go
here then and then repair this
hey cj come palamas
now we're out of the water again we're
going everywhere
everywhere apart from we haven't gone
back to the
no we have we've even been back to the
desert as well
but even through
adversity within
and without
she had grown her determination sean
bright
his sand
i hope you find your peace
now what
okay can i keep rising it
nope
jump
hey charlie p almost there chilling wins
shook her to the bone still she climbed
surely that would be ice we'll let it
we'll let them off
she'd be sliding right back down
ice does work oh no i forgot to break it
first
don't fall all the way down
makes it like a lighter blue color
almost there
good day saru let me through
and let's finish this
glad we're on the same page
every stride pushing against
storm
and snow
defiant
unwavering
give me back my friend
they're gone now that's bo
that's where i last saw
lump herman how are you here
not sure i'm so glad after i left you
i felt i never should have let you stay
behind lumpsy how
far you come you've grown big lump
did right thing oh thanks lump
what a cutie
have to georgia but we'll always
be there in the memory and remembering
goodbye
cheers wind
this is it is this it
is this it
hello dragon
georgia readied herself
oh
right this is it uh
hello bit of an anti-climax
when she first set out georgia wanted to
understand why these terrible events had
happened
but now she realized that regardless of
how her adventure ended
the journey had forever changed her
standing there she felt
what should we feel reflective or battle
ready
or calm but i'm thinking either battle
ready or
reflective what do you guys think
it was good bat already sydney says she
is ready
or calm i'm gonna go battle really
though i'm ready
she had the fortitude to face whatever
battles lay ahead
the words were at her command
she was powerful she was ready
but come out i'm ready to face you in
combat
oh damn it's right there
that wasn't a cave at all i really don't
think you are
i want an eye poke why did all of this
happen
why did you do this why
no one's ever asked why before
it is
uh i'm just gonna ignore your breath
stinky
you can't just make me this
the ender of the world not this one
all things must come to an end your
friends
your family you
not if i can help it in time
even dragons fade ponder this
upon
[Music]
what am i gonna do
hello i'm back up
one person can make a difference
i know that now you have been reading
the wrong
stories little one
sometimes things just
end
if you want to end this world you're
going to have to go
through me yes
that's what i've been trying to do
you're a bit useless and yeah
then it seems we have you can't hurt me
and what is your solution
i'm not sure can we come to an
understanding
very well you may ask
me one question make this one
count oh okay guys
let's do this together do you really
want to do it and destroy this world
the fireflies what are they where does
the power come from
astoria it's really dying isn't it
i would say either
the astoria one or
the the question about do you actually
want to destroy worlds
i don't know i guess like it'd be cool
to know where the fireflies come from it
just seems a little bit like weird
foreign
saw the fireflies what are they
what are they exactly i've been
collecting them they've kind of be a
side
thing to this whole narrative but
let's ask the one fateful question
uh to be about the fireflies uh okay so
sydney
says do you really want to do it
um anyone else want to chime in anyone
else wanna have a little little say
astoria is it really dying or
do you really wanna destroy the world
making questions existence okay
do you really want to do it destroy this
world
what this is not about what i
want it is about
what is then what do you want
i am feared
if i could want i would not
want that oh he wants people to like him
but i cannot choose my wants
no more than i can choose my purpose
still when i rest
when i dream that is good
i understand feeling tired
for me too everything has been about the
journey
the fight then perhaps we both
need to rest you have had your one
question
i have work to do damn
we didn't really get much
i've overcome so much to get here i've
had to face what i am
and what i'm it was a stroke i think it
oh
it can be yours too
you can change things
what why
i did not aim for you
some things are not to be changed
not to be stopped they must be
accepted i can't
i can't accept this
you can you will
is that the end learn
to dream again
i just got an achievement called the end
question mark
what happened
oh hello it's
all gone i'm afraid
it can't be this is reminding me of um
i'm gone
just give me never running story vibes
why can't i save it there was nothing to
be done
everything has a time to go but i don't
want that i feel like a failure
that's silly you didn't fail because you
couldn't
win i
[Music]
ancient energies born of the same cycle
between you them and your book
you'll work it out wait what do you mean
come back
please come back
[Music]
there's only one place left to look
your journal this book
this book no the journal
astoria was gone but the fireflies still
remained
waiting for a new beginning
you're rebuilding the world aren't you
and you're starting with my memory oh
it's all the cool things that she met
a fruitful work
oh nice they're working together that's
cute
a remembrance of home
i've run out of fireflies we're stuck
there's still something missing
hey you're still here firefly can you
help
yes yes i can help that's it firefly
now you're ready for a new story
and i have to say goodbye too
thank you firefly
so the firefighters like build the world
build and maintain the world i guess
start the stories
i never thought i'd see you again
but you're not really here right
hello
you you didn't make it
you knew didn't you that you wouldn't
that's why the firefly came to me
they knew too so
these are my memories of you
that's where you live now isn't it
within me
so
oh that's cute
let's see what adventures lie ahead
hmm
hello journal reading these dusty pages
she's older makes me feel old i reread
them so many times as a kid
taking myself back to those dark moments
reassuring myself it would all be okay
that helped you helped
i still miss gran every day
sometimes i hear her laugh in the back
of my mind
abby reminds me of her insatiably
curious
and fiercely independent i hope she
never loses that
mom's coming to live with us for a bit
i hope her and abby are going to make
some memories of their own
they're already both obsessed with cat
videos and
instasmile abby's birthday is coming up
maybe i'll get her a journal of her own
she says
she wants to be a writer
very cute
there you go lost words be on the page
i love emotions oh she says i'm still
did this
okay
[Music]
sorry i'm very emotional person oh man
no that was a very good game
very um i think i've already said in the
first one but
i think this would be a like an awesome
game for kids to play i've already told
my mom about it
i'm getting all emotional stop it but i
need to talk about the cake
um i've already talked around about it
like i think my um
nieces should play this game because i
think um it'd be really fun for kids
and i think it's like a really nice way
for kids to learn about like
you know grief and loss and
and all of these things and mental
health as well i mean i
definitely touched on like depression
and slipping into things like that
and as a kid all that stuff is so
confusing and
um you're driven way more by your
emotions as a kid as well so
this would be like a really good game to
play um
and then as an adult playing it you
you like can relate because i think a
lot of us have like
lost people right and yeah it's just
like
it's like you get to kind of reflect
back on your own experiences and you're
like
oh it's very cute it's very sweet
as for the mechanics i love the two
different worlds um
and this is why it's also very good for
a kid because
uh you know you have like your fun beats
and then your serious beats
it never gets too serious and too sad
there's always some like fun adventure
bit to kind of
be a buffer in between the more the more
serious
sad parts um so i like that
and it's really cool to uh
use you know the words as like um
different
stepping plates on a platform it's very
intuitive
for kids don't really need to think much
about it
and then if you fall you come straight
back you know there's no dying in this
game so
um it's it's definitely heavily heavily
focused on narrative but i think that's
that's really nice and especially when
you're playing as a kid
like it's just a nice thing um to do
because you don't
ever this this game is obviously about
mental health so why would you
allow kids to just keep dying and get
frustrated and feel like they're not
good enough at the game that's trying to
tell you that
you know life is way about way more than
just that
so yeah overall
very sweet and lovely play through if um
if you have uh if you know any kids that
might want to play this game i would say
definitely definitely do um
you can search us on steam i don't know
if it's on any consoles or whatever but
it was a lovely little playthrough thank
you
guys for um
[Music]
don't be sorry about that uh thank you
guys for following me
on this little journey i know this game
is extremely different to
what we normally play here but honestly
i remember back when i started the
channel i used to play a lot
of indie games and i do want to still
keep doing that because
i want to give indie developers you know
a bit of props
because they do all of this with very
small teams and sometimes they do it
alongside like full-time jobs and stuff
and
i'd like to actually check out um
more games by indie developers and not
only that but also
i i find some like it's the indie games
that usually have like
quite unique and different mechanics
because of the amount of constraints
that they have to work under
um and also because they don't have as
many constraints given to them by
like you know big publishers and um
by the expectations of the audiences
that they already have and
all these types of things so i would
like to play more indie games basically
the tlcr of that rant
um next month uh yeah they are a uk dev
the funny thing about this is i was
talking to my lead about it in work
um because i work as a game designer and
i was like oh yeah i've been playing
because he always asks
have you been playing any games and i
said yeah i was playing this game
quarter
lost words and he he just said oh yeah
my friend made that no my friend
my friend is the guy who like literally
came up with that idea
and made it and i was like oh and he was
like yeah i've been
i've been jabbing at him for ages to get
it finished and i was like small world
the game they've seen is such a small
world
it's so weird um but yeah very good game
i love the meaning i i think it's great
i'd like to see more games with a heavy
emphasis on narrative and meaning
and you know mental well-being
and not relying on just like you know
death and
shooting mechanics that are in a lot of
games but
not to say that you can't also tell a
really good story and have like um
mental health uh stuff
with with them killing and shooting and
dying because i mean like
hellblade did really good at that um
anyway i'm gonna stop ranting now
um i think
there you go if you want more from
sketchbook please follow us on social
media at
lost words game
thank you for playing thank you for
making
very emotional journey
[Music]
hey clay saw one two three four five six
seven
okay so that's that i will see you back
here
next week thank you again for sticking
around
and i hope you enjoyed that game because
i did